[Music]
the changing world order
the times ahead will be radically
different from those that we've
experienced in our lifetimes
though similar to many times before
how do i know that
because they always have been
[Music]
over my roughly 50 years of global
macroeconomic investing
i've learned the hard way that the most
important events that surprised me
did so because they never happened in my
lifetime
these painful surprises led me to study
the last 500 years of history for
similar situations where i saw that they
had indeed happened many times before
with the ups and the downs of the dutch
[Music]
british
and u.s empires
and every time they did it was a sign of
the changing world order
this study taught me valuable lessons
that i'm going to pass along to you here
in a distilled form
you can find the comprehensive version
in my book principles for dealing with
the changing world order
let me begin with a story that brought
me to this point about how i learned to
anticipate the future by studying the
past
[Music]
in 1971 when i was a young clerk on the
floor of the new york stock exchange the
united states ran out of money and
defaulted on its debts
that's right the u.s ran out of money
how
well back then gold was the money used
in transactions between countries
paper money like the dollar was like
checks in a checkbook in that it had no
value other than it could be exchanged
for gold which was the real money
at the time the united states was
spending a lot more money than it was
earning by writing a lot more of these
paper money checks than it had gold in
the bank to exchange for them
as people turned these checks into the
bank for gold money the amount of gold
in the u.s started to dwindle it soon
became obvious that the u.s couldn't
keep its promises for all the existing
paper money so people holding dollars
rush to exchange them before the gold
ran out
recognizing that the u.s was going to
run out of real money
on sunday evening august 15th president
nixon went on television to tell the
world that the us was breaking its
promise to let people exchange their
dollars for gold of course he didn't say
it that way he said it more
diplomatically without making it clear
that the united states was defaulting
strength of a nation's currency is based
on the strength of that nation's economy
and the american economy is by far the
strongest in the world
accordingly i have directed the
secretary of the treasury to take the
action necessary to defend the dollar
against the speculators
i have directed secretary connelly to
suspend temporarily the convertibility
of the dollar into gold or other reserve
assets
except in amounts and conditions
determined to be in the interest of
monetary stability and in the best
interest of the united states
i watched in ore
realizing that money as we understood it
was ending
what a crisis
i expected the stock market to plunge
the next day so i got on the exchange
floor early to prepare
when the opening bell rang pandemonium
broke out but not the kind i expected
the market was up
way up
and went on to rise nearly 25
that surprised me because i never
experienced a currency devaluation
before
when i dug into history i discovered
that the exact same thing happened in
1933
and had the exact same effect then paper
dollars were also linked to gold
which the us was running out of because
it was spending more paper money checks
then it had gold to exchange for them
and president roosevelt announced on the
radio that he would break the country's
promise to exchange dollars for gold it
was then that i issued the proclamation
providing for the national bank holiday
and this was the first step in the
government's reconstruction of our
financial and economic fabric
the second step
last thursday
was the legislation promptly and
patriotically passed by the congress
confirming my proclamation and
broadening my powers
so that it became possible in view of
the requirement of time
to extend the holiday and lift the ban
of that holiday gradually in the days to
come this law also gave authority
in both cases breaking the link to gold
allowed the us to continue spending more
than it earned
simply by printing more paper dollars
since there was an increase in the
number of dollars without an increase in
the country's wealth the value of each
dollar fell
as these new dollars entered the market
without a corresponding increase in
productivity they went to buy lots of
stocks gold and commodities
and hence caused their prices to rise
as i studied more history i saw that the
exact same thing happened many many
times before
i saw that since the beginning of time
when governments spent much more than
they took in in taxes
and conditions got bad
they ran out of money and they needed
more
so they printed more
a lot more
which made its value full and made the
prices of most everything including
stocks gold and commodities rise
that's when i first learned the
principle that when central banks print
a lot of money to relieve a crisis buy
stocks gold and commodities because
their value will rise and the value of
paper money will fall this printing of
money is also what happened in 2008 to
relieve the mortgage driven debt crisis
and in 2020
to relieve the pandemic-driven economic
crisis
and it almost certainly will happen in
the future
so i suggest that you keep this
principle in mind
these experiences gave me another
principle which is to understand what is
coming at you you need to understand
what happened before you
that principle led me to study how the
roaring 20s bubble
turned into the 1930s depression
which gave me the lessons that allowed
me to anticipate and profit from
the 2007 bubble
turning into the 2008 bust
[Music]
all these experiences led me to develop
an almost instinctual urge to look to
the past for similar situations to learn
how to handle the future well
changing orders
[Music]
over the last few years three big things
that hadn't happened in my lifetime
prompted me to do this study
first countries didn't have enough money
to pay their debts
even after lowering interest rates to
zero
so their central banks began printing
lots of money to do so
second
big internal conflicts emerge due to
growing gaps in wealth and values this
showed up in political populism and
polarization between the left who want
to redistribute wealth and the right who
want to defend those holding the wealth
and third increasing external conflict
between a rising great power and the
leading great power as is now happening
with china and the united states
so i looked back
i saw that all these had happened
together before many times
and nearly always led to changing
domestic and world orders
the last time this sequence happened was
from 1930 to 1945.
what exactly is an order you might ask
it's a governing system for people
dealing with each other
there are internal orders for governing
within countries typically laid out in
constitutions
and there is a world order for governing
between countries typically laid out in
treaties
internal orders change at different
times than world orders the weather
within or between countries
these orders typically change after wars
civil wars within countries
international wars between countries
they happen when revolutionary new
forces defeat weak old orders
for example the u.s internal order was
laid out in the constitution in 1789
after the american revolution and it is
still operating today even after the
american civil war
russia got rid of its old order and
established a new one with the russian
revolution in 1917 which ended in 1991
with a relatively bloodless revolution
china began its current internal order
in 1949 when the chinese communist party
won the civil war
you get the idea
the current world order commonly called
the american world order formed after
the allied victory in world war ii when
the u.s emerged as the dominant world
power it was set out in agreements and
treaties for how global governance and
monetary systems work in 1944 the new
world monetary system was laid out in
the bretton woods agreement and
established the dollar as the world's
leading reserve currency
a reserve currency is a currency that is
commonly accepted around the world and
having one is a key factor in a country
becoming the richest and most powerful
empire
with a new dominant power and monetary
system established a new world order
begins
these changes take place in a timeless
and universal cycle that i call the big
cycle
i'll start with a quick overview
then give you a more complete version
and then direct you to my book if you
want more
as i studied the 10 most powerful
empires over the last 500 years and the
last three reserve currencies
it took me through the rise and decline
of the dutch empire and the gilder
the british empire and the pound
the rise and early decline in the united
states empire in the dollar
and the decline and rise of the chinese
empire and its currencies as well as the
rise and decline of the spanish
german
french
indian
japanese russian and ottoman empires
along with their significant conflicts
as measured in this chart
to understand china's patterns better i
also studied the rise and fall of
chinese dynasties and their monies back
to the year 600
because looking at all these measures at
once can be confusing i'll focus on the
four most important ones the dutch
british us and chinese
you'll quickly notice the pattern
now let's simplify the form a bit
as you can see they transpired in
overlapping cycles that lasted about 250
years with 10 to 20 year transition
periods between them
typically these transitions have been
periods of great conflict because
leading powers don't decline without a
fight
so how am i measuring an empire's power
in this study i used eight metrics each
country's measure of total power is
derived by averaging them together they
are
education inventiveness and technology
development competitiveness in global
markets economic output share of world
trade
military strength the power of their
financial center for capital markets and
the strength of their currency as a
reserve currency
because these powers are measurable we
can see how strong each country is now
was in the past and whether they're
rising or declining
by examining the sequences from many
countries
we can see how a typical cycle
transpires
and because the wiggles can be confusing
we can simplify it a bit to focus on the
pattern of cause effect relationships
that drive the rise and decline of a
typical empire
as you can see better education
typically leads to increased innovation
and technology development and with a
lag the establishment of the currency as
a reserve currency
you can also see that these forces then
declined in a similar order reinforcing
each other's decline
let's now look at the typical sequence
of events going on inside a country that
produces these rises and declines
in a nutshell the big cycle typically
begins after a major conflict often a
war establishes the new leading power
and the new world order
because no one wants to challenge this
power a period of peace and prosperity
typically follows
as people get used to this peace and
prosperity they increasingly bet on it
continuing they borrow money to do that
which eventually leads to a financial
bubble
the empire's share of trade grows and
when most transactions are conducted in
its currency
it becomes a reserve currency
which leads to even more borrowing
at the same time this increased
prosperity distributes wealth unevenly
so the wealth gap typically grows
between the rich haves and the poor
have-nots
eventually the financial bubble bursts
which leads to the printing of money
and increased internal conflict between
the rich and the poor which leads to
some form of revolution to redistribute
well
this can happen peacefully or as a civil
war
while the empire struggles with this
internal conflict its power diminishes
relative to external rival powers on the
rise
when a new rising power gets strong
enough to compete with the dominant
power that is having domestic breakdowns
external conflicts
most typically wars take place
out of these internal and external wars
come new winners and losers
then the winners get together to create
the new world order
and the cycle begins again
as i looked back i saw that these cause
and effect relationships drove the
cycles of rises and declines all the way
back to the roman empire i saw how the
stories of each one of these cycles
blended together with others before
during and after in the same way as each
individual story blends with others to
make the epic 500 year story that is our
collective history
and like human life
no
cycles
are exactly the same but most are
similar
they're driven by logical cause and
effect relationships that progress
through stages from birth
to strength and maturity
to weakness and inevitably decline
however that's like saying a person's
life cycle takes 80 years on average
without recognizing that many are much
shorter and many are longer
while age can be a good indicator of
future longevity a better way is to look
at health indicators
one can do that with empires and they're
vital signs too
i found that by watching the indicators
of power change i was able to see what
stage a country was in which helped me
to anticipate what was likely to come
next
now i'll take you through the big cycle
in more detail
give me 20 minutes and i'll give you the
last 500 years of history
and show you the similar patterns across
the dutch british
us
and chinese empires
500 years of big cycles
i'm going to describe the typical cycle
by dividing it into three phases
the rise the top and the decline
the rise
successful new waters that rise both
internal and external are typically
started by powerful revolutionary
leaders doing four things
first they win power by gaining more
support than the opposition
second they consolidate power by
converting weakening or eliminating the
opposition so they don't stand in their
way third they establish systems and
institutions that make the country work
well and fourth they pick their
successors well or create systems that
do that
because a great empire requires many
great leaders over several generations
at this stage soon after winning the
fight
there is typically a period of peace and
growing prosperity because the
leadership is clearly dominant and has
broad support so no one wants to fight
it
during this phase leaders within the
country have to design an excellent
system to raise the country's wealth and
power first and foremost to be great
they must have strong education which is
not just teaching knowledge and skills
but also
strong character civility and work ethic
these are typically taught in the family
schools and religious institutions that
provides a healthy respect for rules and
laws order within society low corruption
and enables them to unite behind a
common purpose and work well together as
they do this they increasingly shift
from producing basic products to
innovating and inventing new
technologies
[Music]
for example the dutch rose to defeat the
habsburg empire
and become superbly educated they became
so inventive that they came up with a
quarter of all major inventions in the
world the most important of which was
the invention of ships that could travel
around the world to collect great riches
and the invention of capitalism as we
know it today to finance those voyages
they like all leading empires enhance
their thinking by being open to the best
thinking in the world
as a result the people in the country
become more productive and more
competitive in world markets which shows
up in their growing economic output and
rising share of world trade
you can see this happening now as the us
and china are roughly comparable in both
their economic outputs and their shares
of world trade
as countries trade more globally they
must protect their trade routes and
their foreign interests from attack so
they develop great military strength if
done well this virtuous cycle leads to
strong income growth
which can be used to finance investments
in education
infrastructure and research and
development they must also develop
systems to incentivize and empower those
that have the ability to make or take
wealth
in all of these cases the most
successful empires
used a capitalist approach
[Music]
to develop productive entrepreneurs
even china which is run by the chinese
communist party used the form of this
capitalist approach
[Music]
deng xiaoping when asked about this said
it doesn't matter if it's a white cat or
a black cat as long as it catches mice
and
it's glorious to be rich
to do this well they must develop their
capital markets
most importantly their lending
bond and stock markets
that allows people to convert their
savings into investments
to fund invention and development
and share in the successes of those who
make great things happen
the dutch created the first publicly
listed company the dutch east india
company and the first stock market to
fund it which were integral parts of the
system that produced massive wealth and
power
as a natural consequence the greatest
empires developed the world's leading
financial centers for attracting and
distributing the world's capital
amsterdam was the world's financial
center when the dutch were preeminent
london when the british were on top new
york is now
and china is quickly developing its
financial centers
most importantly the capitalists the
governments and the military must work
together
not only did the dutch work well
together they were one in the same
the dutch east india company was granted
a trade monopoly from the government and
had its own officially sanctioned
military to go out into the global
markets to make and take wealth
the british followed with the british
east india company and had a similar
coordination of their government
business and military operations
the u.s military-industrial complex
followed suit
as does the chinese system today
as the country becomes the largest
international trading empire its
transactions can be paid with its
currency
making it the preferred global medium of
exchange
and because their currency is so widely
accepted and frequently used people
around the world want to save in it
making it the preferred storehold of
wealth
and thus the world's leading reserve
currency
the gilder was the world's main reserve
currency when the dutch-led world trade
the pound was when the british led
and the dollar has been since the u.s
led
naturally china's currency is
increasingly being used as a reserve
currency
having a reserve currency enables the
empire to borrow more than other
countries
that advantage is huge
[Music]
think about it people all over the world
are eager to save and hence lend back
their currency to the empire countries
without a reserve currency don't have
that
and when the empire runs out of its own
money
remember the united states in 1971
they can always print more
the exorbitant privilege afforded by the
empire's reserve currency
leads borrowing to increase
and the beginning of a financial bubble
this series of cause-and-effect
relationships leading to mutually
supportive financial political and
military powers bolstered by the
borrowing power of a reserve currency
have gone together since history began
to be recorded all the empires that
became the most powerful in the world
followed this path
to the top
[Music]
while in the top phase most of these
strengths are sustained embedded within
the fruits of their success are the
seeds of their decline
as a rule as people in these rich and
powerful countries earn more
that makes them more expensive and less
competitive relative to people in other
countries who are willing to work for
less
at the same time people in other
countries naturally copy the methods and
technologies of the leading power which
further reduces the leading power's
competitiveness
for example british shipbuilders had
less expensive workers than dutch
shipbuilders
so they hired dutch designers to design
better ships
that were built by less expensive
british workers making them more
competitive which led the british to
rise and the dutch to decline
also as people become richer they tend
not to work as hard
they enjoy more leisure pursue the finer
and less productive things in life and
at the extreme become decadent
values change from generation to
generation during the rise to the top
from those who had to fight to achieve
wealth and power to those who inherited
it
they're less battle-hardened steeped in
luxuries and accustomed to the easy life
which makes them more vulnerable to
challenges the golden era of the dutch
empire
[Music]
and the victorian era of the british
empire
[Applause]
were such high prosperity periods like
this
as people get used to doing well they
increasingly bet on the good times
continuing
and borrow money to do that which grows
into financial bubbles
naturally the financial gains come
unevenly so the wealth gap grows
wealth gaps are self-reinforcing because
rich people use their greater resources
to reinforce their powers
for example they give greater privileges
to their children like better education
and they influence the political system
to their advantage
this causes the gaps in values politics
and opportunities to grow between the
rich haves
and the poor have-nots
those who are less well-off feel the
system is unfair so resentments grow but
as long as the living standards of most
people are still rising these gaps and
resentments don't boil over into
conflict
having the world's reserve currency
inevitably leads to borrowing
excessively and contributes to the
country building up large debts with
foreign lenders while this boosts
spending power over the short term
it weakens the country's financial
health and weakens the currency over the
long term
in other words when borrowing and
spending are strong the empire appears
very strong
but its finances are in fact being
weakened
[Music]
the borrowing sustains the country's
power beyond its fundamentals by
financing both domestic over consumption
and international military conflicts
required to maintain the empire
inevitably the cost of maintaining and
defending the empire becomes greater
than the revenue it brings in so having
an empire becomes unprofitable
for example the dutch empire
overextended around the world
and fought war after increasingly
expensive war with the british and other
european powers to protect its territory
and trade routes the british empire
similarly became massive bureaucratic
and lost its competitive advantages as
rival powers
particularly germany sword
leading to an increasingly expensive
arms race and world war
the u.s has spent about eight trillion
dollars on foreign wars and their
consequences since september 11
and trillions more for other military
operations and for supporting military
bases in 70 countries
and it still isn't spending enough to
support its military competition with
china in the area around china
in this cycle the richer countries
eventually get deeper into debt by
borrowing from poorer countries that
save more it's one of the early signs of
a wealth and powershift
this started in the united states in the
1980s when it had a per capita income 40
times that of china's and started
borrowing from chinese who wanted to
save in dollars because the dollar was
the world's reserve currency
similarly the british borrowed a lot of
money from its much poorer colonies
and the dutch did the same at their top
if the empire begins to run out of new
lenders those holding their currency
begin to look to sell and get out
rather than to buy
save
lend and get in
[Music]
and the strength of the empire begins to
decline
the decline
the decline comes from internal economic
weakness together with internal fighting
or costly external fighting or both
typically the decline comes gradually
and then very suddenly
when debts become very large
and there is an economic downturn
and the empire can no longer borrow the
money necessary to repay its debts
the financial bubble bursts
this creates great domestic hardships
and forces the country to choose between
defaulting on its debts or printing a
lot of new money
it always chooses to print a lot of new
money
at first gradually and eventually
massively
that devalues the currency and raises
inflation
for the dutch this was the financial
crisis brought about by financial
excesses and paying for the fourth
anglo-dutch war
similarly for the british it was paying
for its financial excesses and its debts
from the two world wars
and for the u.s it's been three cycles
of debt finance booms and busts since
the 90s with the central bank stepping
in each time with stronger measures
when the government has problems funding
itself when there are bad economic
conditions
and living standards for most people are
declining
and there are large wealth
values
and political gaps
internal conflict between the rich and
the poor as well as different ethnic
religious and racial groups greatly
increases this leads to political
extremism that shows up as populism of
the left or the right those of the left
seek to redistribute the wealth while
those of the right seek to maintain the
wealth in the hands of the rich
typically during such times taxes on the
rich rise and when the rich fear their
wealth and well-being will be taken away
they move to places assets and
currencies they feel safer in
these outflows reduce the empire's tax
revenue which leads to a classic
self-reinforcing hollowing out process
when the flight of wealth gets bad
enough governments outlaw it
those seeking to get out begin to panic
these turbulent conditions undermine
productivity
which shrinks the economic pie and
causes more conflict about how to divide
the shrinking resources
populous leaders emerge from both sides
and pledge to take control and bring
about order
that's when democracy is most challenged
because it fails to control the anarchy
and it is when the move to a strong
populous leader who will bring order to
the chaos is most likely
as conflict within the country escalates
it leads to some form of revolution or
civil war to redistribute wealth and
force the necessary big changes
this can be peaceful and maintain the
existing order
but it's more often violent and changes
for example the roosevelt revolution to
redistribute wealth was relatively
peaceful and maintained the existing
internal order
while the french revolution
the russian revolution
and the chinese revolution were much
more violent
and led to new internal orders
this internal conflict makes the empire
weak and vulnerable to rising external
rivals who seeing this domestic weakness
are more inclined to mount a challenge
this raises the risk of great
international conflict especially if the
rival has built up a comparable military
defending oneself and one's empire
against rivals requires great military
spending
which has to occur as domestic economic
conditions are deteriorating and the
empire can least afford it
since there is no viable system for
peacefully adjudicating international
disputes these conflicts are typically
resolved through tests of power
[Music]
as bolder challenges are made the
leading empire is faced with the
difficult choice of fighting or
retreating
fighting and losing is the worst outcome
but retreating is bad too as it cedes
progress to the rival and signals that
the empire is weak to those countries
that are considering which side to be on
poor economic conditions cause more
fighting for wealth and power which
inevitably leads to some kind of war
wars are terribly costly at the same
time they produce the tectonic shifts
that realign the new waters
to the new realities of wealth and power
in the world when those holding the
reserve currency and debt of the
declining empire lose faith and sell
them that marks the end of its big cycle
of the roughly 750 currencies that
existed since 1700 less than 20 percent
now exist
and all of them have been devalued
for the dutch this happened after their
defeat in the fourth anglo-dutch war
when they weren't able to repay the
massive debts they built up during it
this led to a run on the bank of
amsterdam
and a desperate sell-off
forcing massive money printing
which devalued the currency
and the empire into irrelevance
for the british this happened after
world war ii
when despite their victory they could
not repay the massive debts they
borrowed to fund their war effort this
led to a series of money printing
devaluations
and sell-offs in the british pound
as the us and the dollar emerged
dominant and created a new world order
at the time of this recording the united
states hasn't yet reached this point
while it has massive debt it spends more
than it earns and funds this deficit
with more borrowing and printing huge
amounts of new money
the big sell-off in dollars and dollar
debt hasn't yet begun
and while there are great internal and
external conflicts occurring for all the
classic reasons they've not yet crossed
the line to become wars eventually out
of these conflicts whether they're
violent or not
come new winners who get together and
restructure the losers debts and
political systems
and establish the new world water
then the old cycle and empire ends and
the new one begins
and they do it all over again
that's a lot of detail i just threw at
you to paint a picture of how the
typical big cycle transpires of course
not all of them transpire in exactly
this way but most largely do so much so
that it seems like the stories of rises
and declines stay essentially the same
and the only things that change are the
clothes the characters wear and the
technologies they use
so where are we heading
[Music]
the future
most empires have their time in the sun
and inevitably decline
[Music]
reversing a decline is difficult because
that requires undoing a lot that's
already been done but it's possible
by looking at these indicators it's
pretty easy to see which stage of the
big cycle an empire is in
how fit it is and whether its condition
is improving
or worsening
which can help one estimate how many
years it has left
still
these estimates aren't precise and the
cycle can be extended if those in charge
pay attention to their vital signs and
improve them
for example knowing that a person is 60
years old
how fit they are
whether they smoke or not and a few
other basic vital signs
one can estimate the person's longevity
[Music]
one can do that with empires and their
vital signs too
it won't be precise
but it will be broadly indicative and
give clear direction on steps to take to
increase longevity
it's most often the case that a nation's
greatest war is with itself
over whether or not it can make the hard
decisions needed to sustain success
as for what we need to do it comes down
to just two things
earn more than we spend
and treat each other well
all other things i mentioned strong
education inventiveness being
competitive and all the rest
are just ways of getting at these two
things
it's easy to measure if we're doing them
so like people who want to get fit
let's get on the program and improve our
vitals
let's do that individually and
collectively
my goal for sharing this picture of how
the world works and a few principles for
dealing with it well is to help you
recognize where we are and the
challenges we face
and to make the wise decisions needed to
navigate these times well
[Music]
since there is a lot more to discuss and
we are out of time you can learn more in
my book principles for dealing with the
changing world water and i look forward
to continuing this conversation at
economicprinciples.org and on social
media
thank you and may the force of evolution
be with
[Music]
so
so
[Music]
you